you know we try to keep this show very
PG-13 so I just want to apologize to
anyone who is listening over on the
televised mental institution of MSNBC
yesterday Joy Reed blonde woman Joy Reed
uh they cut to Commercial and well
listen to what Joy Reed sounds like when
she doesn't think she's on camera over
the weekend President Biden said he's
ready to take action if Congress is
serious about solving the Border
issue if that bill were the law today
I'd shut down the border right now and
fix it quickly and Congress needs to get
it done starting another
War oh did Joy Reed just say the quiet
part out loud that Joe Biden because
what's happening at the border and they
were also playing a clip of Iran earlier
that Joe Biden's about to start another
effn War you guys know I Love the clips
when these robots these pre-programmed
robots who are just paid by the machine
to spout nonsense when they start
breaking down and they actually tell you
the truth well they came back from
commercial and she uh well she lied
again on why she even said that so I
just want apologize very quickly uh I
was chatting during a clip that was
playing um and you know we try to keep
this show very PG-13 so I just want to
apologize to anyone who is listening to
my behind the scenes chatter uh deeply
deeply apologize for that cuz you know
it's pg3 up around here so thank you to
you all for watching the read out and
inside with J saki start oh my God you
know I was just you know we didn't
realize and that's when I tell you the
truth when we're going to Commercial and
I start chatting with other people they
like think how reverse that is from what
I do here I'm telling you what I think
you can agree you can disagree you can
love me for it you can hate me for it
but do you think like when we throw to a
clip that I'm turning to them and being
like here's how I really feel about that
like it's such profound evil
[Music]
BS